hello everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you're
all doing fine
so today's class will be again for men
and women the same if you are a woman
you can do the class with high heels
with your tongue shoes maybe not the
warm up the warm up is the only thing
where you
should do it barefoot or with flat shoes
we will use a stick for training the
position of our arms in the embrace and
we will also use the metronome to have a
steady reference for the time
and today we will do the following we
will take the
projection work that we have been doing
in the last videos yeah the projection
of the free leg and we will combine it
with a transfer of weight and close of
the free leg to have the complete step
yeah we will do it to the side we will
do it front and we will do it back
yeah
and we will do it slowly
following the beat of the metronome and
we will do it also faster in double time
okay when we do it slowly it will be an
extra
workout for our balance our control our
core and our flow okay
so
at the end of the class we will do a
little sequence combining all the
directions yeah front side back
with the full step and i will give you
two versions of the exercise first i
will show it
using the technique for men
and then
i will add two extra exercises at the
end in which i will do a variation of
the sequence for women
and i will also show the technique for
women because it changes a little bit
from the mind especially for the back
steps okay
so that will be the program today i hope
you enjoy it let's start with the warm
up okay let's start with the warm-up so
put your feet together
straight posture relax
look front and relax the arms and the
shoulders okay and we start with
shoulder rotations remember to do them
slowly and big as big as you can and
remember to keep your elbows relaxed
yeah don't bend them when the shoulders
go up don't do this yeah
okay let's do it eight times
one
two
slowly
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight okay now we do arm circles
remember to keep the shoulders down yeah
don't move them up keep them down keep
the elbows straight as well don't bend
them when the hands are
up yeah
don't do this
keep the elbows always straight and pass
the hands behind your back so that you
stretch the chest okay
let's do it three times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay very good relax the arms and now we
stretch the side of our torso so you
raise one arm make sure that the elbow
is straight also here yeah
and then you slide the hand down your
leg
until you can touch your knee more or
less and then you hold the stretch for
three seconds
and then you use the hand that is up to
pull yourself up again and then you drop
the arm and you repeat to the other side
okay
so let's do it four times to each side
let's go one raise the arm
slide down your leg
touch the knee
hold the stretch
and up and drop the arm okay
one
go down the leg
touch the knee hold it
and up
two arms up
go down
touch the knee hold it
and up
two go down
touch the knee hold it
and up
three
around the leg
hold the stretch
and up
three
go down your leg
hold the stretch
and up
four
go down your leg hold the stretch
and up
and forward
pull down the leg touch the knee hold it
and up
okay now open your legs a little bit
wider than your shoulders bend your
knees a little bit
and then
uh keep your hip straight here look in
front all the time and your head also
look in front all the time and make a
circle with your arms
place your hands below the chest yeah
not too high below the chest is fine and
then rotate the torso
left and right yeah make sure that you
are rotating the torso here
i'm not just moving the arms alone okay
you have to move
the torso left and right and the arms
don't do anything the arms just come
together with the torso in one block
okay then you are doing the exercise
properly
okay let's do it eight times twice okay
let's go on
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight eight more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight okay
now stretch knees
and then put your hands behind your head
and then keeping the knees straight and
the heels on the floor you burn from the
hip forward and down keeping your
back straight until your back is
parallel with the floor and then you
continue going down using the weight of
your head bend the back and then relax
here when you are down and bounce three
times
one two three
and then go up slowly
okay
so we do it eight times let's go
one go down slowly
and
bounce back bounce
go up
two
go down keep the back straight bounce
once two
three
and one
three go down
keep the back straight
then bounce back
palms
and walk
forward
go down
bounce back bounce
back straight and go up
five
go down
[Music]
bounce pass bounce
and walk
six
down slowly relax balance parts
go down
bounce back bounce
and go up okay
now grab your hips with your hands and
keep the knees straight
and we do circles with
our hip yeah so you start by going back
with the hip
and then you move your hip to the side
you have to be careful that you move the
hip and not the head to the other side
yeah your hip has to move and not the
head
so hip to the side and then forward and
then to the other side and then back
so we do it eight times in one direction
and then eight times in the other
direction okay let's go ah
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight and then change direction one
two
three
four make them big yeah five
six
seven
and eight
okay now straight again and put your
feet together
okay feet touching each other completely
parallel and touching each other okay
knees of course as well
together and
you can keep your hands in your hips and
you bend your knees you bounce three
times one two three very relaxed then
you stretch the knees
and then you go up on the toes and the
ball of your foot yeah try that your
legs stay together and they don't open
yeah keep them together keep your core
tight as well and then down slowly and
we'll repeat okay we do it eight times
and one
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
hold it a few seconds
and then go down slowly controlled yeah
two
bounce pass pass
go up
and
go down
three
bounce balance bounce
then go up keep your feet together
go down four
bounce backs bounce
go up
hold it
feet together
and down
five pass pass bounce go up
hold it
and go down six
bounce balance bounce
go up
slowly
hold it and go down slowly seven bounce
balance bounce
go up
on the toes
hold it
keep your core tight
go down and then eight bars bounce
bounce go up
keep feet together hold it
and go down slowly okay
and the last exercise stretch for the
back of our legs so you start with feet
together you can keep the hands on the
hips yeah
and then you move one foot behind you
yeah the distance of a long step a big
step and then you bend the forward knee
the knee that is forward
until you feel the back of your leg
straight stretched yeah so keep the heel
on the floor yeah make sure that your
heel doesn't go up keep it on the floor
so that you can stretch and keep the
knees straight okay straight so then
bend forward with this knee with a knee
forward bend forward until you feel a
really good stretch
and then hold it there and let's count
25 seconds
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one two
three
four
five and then stretch the front knee
slowly so that you get
out of the stretch
slowly okay if the balance is difficult
for you you can hold
uh your hand on the wall yeah
for balance yeah but if not try to do it
without help okay so let's stretch the
other leg
feet together straight posture and then
move the other foot behind you
the distance of a big step
yeah
and then go forward with the front knee
yeah go forward keeping the back heel on
the floor and the back knee straight and
then let's count again 25 seconds
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five
six seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five and then stretch the front knee
slowly get out of the stretch
and we are ready let's go for the first
exercise okay in this first exercise we
will start with the side step yeah and
remember that you can use a stick to
work at the same time in the frame of
your embrace yeah the position of your
arms remember if you are a man
start with the stick on top of your
elbows and then bend the right elbow
yeah so that your hand is in front of
the center of your torso a bit below the
chest that would be the center of the
back of the woman yeah and then bend the
left elbow so that your fist is going up
it's pointing up and the palm of your
hand is facing towards your face okay if
you are a woman is the opposite
stick on the elbows on top of the elbows
and then bend the left elbow yeah so
that the left hand is in front of your
torso you can raise it a little bit yeah
to imitate um the top of the back of the
band and then you bend the right elbow
so that your
fingers point up yeah and the palm of
your hand is facing away from your face
you can close the fingers or keep them
open yeah
that's for the arms man and woman okay
and with the legs
we will have four movements yeah for a
complete side step
so you start with your feet together you
leave a bit of space
uh in the direction that you want to go
yeah zero position and then
you put your weight on the opposite leg
of the direction that you want to go
obviously yeah
so now i show you from the front but
later when we do it together i will show
you from the back so you can follow me
with the same layer okay
so zero position
put your weight on the
opposite leg of the direction you want
to do the side step and then on the
first movement
you use a projection that we have been
using in the videos before not to the
side and at the same time you bend your
standing leg a little bit yeah you stand
you start with both legs straight and
then you bend the standing leg on the
second movement you push with the
standing leg towards the side yeah
and as a reaction you slide with the
free foot yeah with the toe
okay so
with the standing leg i'm pushing in
this direction towards that side yeah i
push away and as a reaction
my free foot slides on the floor yeah
that's the second on the third you
transfer the weight yeah that's when you
actually do the step besides that and
you might want to spend a bit of time
with this movement yeah
just shifting
your weight from leg to leg
so that you do it correctly your torso
should stay always
vertical yeah when you change the weight
when you transfer the weight
so don't tilt it yeah don't do something
like this
you have to stay always
straight yeah and also you have to keep
uh your hip moving parallel to the floor
yeah and the distance between the hip
and the floor should be
constant yeah always constant so for
example don't do a u yeah like this
this is wrong or don't go up or don't do
anything that changes this distance
always straight yeah and on the fourth
and last movement we just close the
three leg and we stretch the standing
leg yeah so we have one projection
two
push with the standing leg and slightly
the three foot
three transfer the weight
and four stretch the standing leg and
close the three leg okay that's the area
and with the metronome we will use one
bit per movement yeah
so
i'll show you now
it will be like this we will always
start each movement at the beginning of
the beat when we hear the beat yeah so
it will be
one
two
three
four
one
two
three
four projection push and slide transfer
close projection push and slide transfer
close okay
notice that i am always moving yeah i
don't do projection push and slide
transfer and close no it's all fluid
it's all free okay so let's try together
yeah now i'll show you from behind and
let's do it
twice eight times to both sides okay so
eight times and then eight more
okay
so let's do it
together place a stick
so that you work on your embrace yeah
man or woman
and then
put your weight on the right leg we will
go to the left yeah
and this
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven seven
eight
eight more one
one
two
three
four
five
six
7.
eight
okay
yeah
so
in this exercise
you open the free leg on the one
and you transfer the weight on the three
yeah those two moments the one and the
three are the strongest parts of the
step when you start the step and when
you transfer the weight yeah
okay so let's go to the next one okay in
this exercise we will do again a side
step like in the previous one but we
will do it faster yeah for that in our
metronome which was set to
58 ppm and two beats per bar
something like this yeah
one
two
we will add a subdivision between bits
so it will sound
like
this
one
two and one and two yeah
and this and we will also use to do a
movement of the step yeah this in
musical terms is called double time
because it's like you are doubling the
tempo okay you double your speed
so if you remember the step had four
movements on the first one you project
the free leg and you bend the standing
leg on the second you push with the
standing leg and you slide in the free
leg on the third you transfer the weight
from one leg to the other and on the
fourth you close the leg so with the
metronome it will be like
one two three four one two three four
one two three four projects slide
transfer cross projects like transfer
clothes
okay
so because it's faster we will do it
more times yeah we will do it
uh four times eight okay so 32 inches
so let's do it together
remember to use a stick
yeah
to work on your arms and the frame of
your legs so put the stick
in your arms
put the arms in position zero position
on your feet then put your weight on the
right yeah we'll start towards the left
and let's go together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
hey
let's say one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great
so
even if it's faster huh
try to be precise try to remain precise
with when each phase of the size
starts yeah count one two three four one
two three four and try to put the
projection the push and slide the
transfer of weight and the clothes
exactly on each one of those four
um
moments in time okay and
supervision okay good let's go to the
next one okay in this exercise we will
go forward and back yeah with a change
of weight in between forward change of
weight back change of weight and on yeah
and the movement of our legs will follow
the same logic
uh than the side step yeah so you start
with your feet together you put your
weight on the right leg yeah because we
will use the left leg as the active leg
the leg that always initiates
each step forward and back yeah
and then on the first movement
you bend the standing leg and then you
project with the left leg
forward then on the second movement you
push
backwards with a standing leg so as a
reaction your free leg slides forward on
the third movement you change
the weight and transfer the weight from
one leg to the other be careful with the
balance here yeah and on the fourth
movement you close the free leg and you
change weight
so that you have the left leg again
ready to go back
so the same four movements the first one
is always project with the free leg
and you don't need to do anything with
the
with the standing leg now because you
are already low from the change in
weight so you just stay there yeah
project then push with a standing leg
forward so that your free leg slides
back
then transfer
the weight yeah from one leg to another
and then close the free leg and change
weight again yeah so the left leg is
always
the leg that initiates the step so it's
the active leg
and the right leg is the passive leg
because it comes afterwards it always
follows the active leg yeah
now don't get confused because if i say
passive leg
that doesn't mean that the leg
moves passively yeah
that only means that the leg is going
after the active leg is following the
active leg but the movement of the
passive leg has to have the same
accent dynamic and strength
uh than the active leg okay now a few
tips before we start
of course when you start projecting
forward keep the torso straight yeah so
when you project don't tilt the torso
back yeah keep it always straight and a
little bit forward in the chest forward
yeah
then push and slide when you transfer
the weight be careful with the balance
yeah you have to place your weight from
one on top of one foot to the top on top
of the other foot
and then close the leg now
when you go back the same yeah here
make sure that your projection is not
opening to the side or crossing you
understanding that make sure that it is
going really behind you because if the
leg goes in somewhere direction you will
have balance problems when you transfer
the weight yeah
so make sure that it goes straight
and then
transfer the weight
keeping the balance okay
and remember also that
if you are a woman
you can use a slightly different
technique when you go back yeah let's
say you're here you want to go back so
if you're a man usually you always keep
your hips straight
so when you project back the free foot
looks like this yeah the toes are going
down pointing down on the floor and the
heel is pointing up yeah and then you
change weight but
if you're a woman
when you project you can also open the
hip a little bit in the direction of the
free leg yeah
just rotate the hip very very little
only like this yeah then you push and
slide and then when you transfer the
weight you correct the foot so that when
you change the weight your feet are
parallel parallel yeah
if you overdo
the
rotation of the hip
if you do this
almost like you are doing a
tunnel pose then um this is not good
because then when you uh push and slide
and transfer the weight when you change
weight
you have this position with the feet
they are open yeah and this is really
weird for the change of weight and then
going forward
so my advice is if you want to use this
technique at all as a woman
i recommend it but do it only very very
subtle very little you see my toes on
the free foot are pointing a bit out the
heel is going inside but it's not
extreme yeah the heat is also a bit
rotated but not too much only a little
bit yeah
a bit and then when you transfer the
weight you correct the foot
so that at the end your feet are almost
parallel okay
great
so
we will do it slowly
one movement per beat
yeah 58 bpm
so get ready
put the stick on your elbows put the
arms in gamma embrace man
or woman
then put your weight on the right leg
and the
left leg will be the active leg okay and
we wait
twice eight times
let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
hey
okay okay now let's do it to the other
side yeah
so
we put our weight on the left leg and
the right leg will be the active leg now
okay
let's do it twice sometimes together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
eight more
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
yeah
it looks easy but
it's not because you are doing it slowly
so you need a lot of control and a lot
of balance especially if you want to
keep
the step fluid yeah if you want to
connect every phase of the step every uh
each one of the four steps of the
uh
sorry each one of the four faces of the
step
fluid connected fluidly yeah
by doing it slowly it's difficult that
this will give you a lot of control and
a lot of balance okay so let's go to the
next exercise okay in this exercise we
will do the same forward and back but
faster in double time or down table so
in the metronome we will play an extra
subdivision between beats and it will be
like one two three four one two three
four yeah
projection push and slide transfer and
close yeah one two three four one two
three four yeah now because it's faster
you should have less problems with
balance because you don't spend so much
time in each position
but still
try to
still be precise
with your directions yeah and with the
timing of each phase of the wall yeah
even if it all happens faster try to
still be aware of each movement of the
walk yeah so it will it will be like
one two three four one two three four
yeah even if it's faster still try to
feel when exactly is the projection
happening
the push and slide the transfer of
weight the closer the change of weight
okay
so we will do it
four times
eight
yeah
and we start with the left leg as they
are to play like before so
get ready arms and tangle embrace and
then fit into your position and the
weight is on the right and the left
is free okay
so let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
let's say one
one
two
three
four four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
now we go to the other side and remember
a couple of tips first one during the
whole exercise
keep your torso straight or slightly
forward yeah
don't
have the torso back yeah
and the second
make sure that your
uh passive leg the one that follows the
movement
exactly especially when you go forward
don't close your passive leg too early
yeah
don't close the leg too early
leave it behind
as much as the metronome allows yeah
one two three on the three when you
transfer the weight leave it behind
three four on the three directions still
be straight behind you and not closing
okay
so let's do it again four times eight
and the right leg is the active leg now
the leading leg okay
so put your weight on the left and we
start with right
one
two
three
four
five
six
six seven
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
7 eight
eight
lasted one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we will do a simple
combination with
side steps front steps and back steps
yeah it will look like a long rectangle
yeah and it works like this
so first you have to make sure that you
have enough space in front of you you
need enough space for two big steps
forward yeah that's all you need
and then you do this you start in zero
position and you put your weight on the
right leg yeah the right leg is a
standing leg and then you start with a
side step to the left now if i do a big
size step i would probably step out of
the frame
of the camera
so you won't be able to see what i'm
doing so i will do it small i will do a
very small side step but when you do the
exercise yourself do a big step yeah i
recommend that you do a big step like we
did in the beginning of the class
okay and for each step you do
you do the four stages of the step
which were projection
push and slide transfer of weight and
close yeah
so you start with a side step
projection push and slide transfer and
close then you do two steps forward
starting with the right leg so
projection push and slide
transfer close projection push and slide
transfer flows then you do a side step
to the right projection push and slide
transfer close and then you do two steps
back starting with the left leg
projection push and slide transfer close
projection push on slide
transfer close and from here again in
the beginning you start again okay with
the side step
if you're a woman you could do it like
this you could start here
yeah in front
and then you could start of course with
the arms like this yeah
and then you could start with
the side step to the right yeah to your
right so standing leg is the left and
then you go to the right and then when
you go back you could use this technique
with the hip opening the hip
one two three four and then you
continue with the size step to the left
and then you go forward
when you go forward the technique is
pretty much the same as with as the
technique of the mouth you keep the hips
straight okay
so i will do it in the first form
you can do it in the second form if you
want okay we will do it eight times the
whole rectangle eight times and we will
do it slowly so the metronome is set to
58 bpm on beats only
and we do each phase of the step on one
bit of the metronome okay
so it will be
projection push and slide
transfer close okay very slowly so be
careful with your body
let's go
feet together
weight on the
right leg and we start with a left side
step
one
forward
power
side
back
to
forward
side
back
forward
side
back
four
five
forward
side
[Music]
six
forward
side
by
[Music]
seven
four
forward
side back
eight
forward
over
side
by
back
okay we're finished
with this one
let's go to the last exercise okay in
this last exercise we'll do the same
combination the longer rectangle
uh in dollar time yeah so the metronome
is said to play
subdivisions between steps
yeah
so each step will take half the time
and the phases of the step will be
with a minimum one two three four one
two three four yeah
projection push and slide change of
weight and close yeah it will be
one two three four one two
[Music]
okay so we will do it
twice eight times yeah eight a minute
okay so get ready
straight posture arms and downward raise
zero position and put your weight on the
left on the right foot and we start with
the left side step okay
let's go
one forward
forward
side
back
two
forward
side
back
three
forward
side
back
four
forward
side
back
five
four
side
back
six
forward
side
back
seven
forward
four
side
back
[Music]
eight
forward
side
back
one
two
four
forward
side
back
three
four
side
back
forward
side
back
five
forward
side
back
seven
four
side
back
okay great
now um
as a bonus exercise i will repeat the
last two exercises yeah this combination
slow and fast but using the woman
variation yes starting at the front with
my arms in the position of the woman
embrace i'm using the heat technique so
that you can see it okay
so if you're a woman you want to stay
for this last part okay let's go okay in
this extra exercise with the same
rectangle the same figure with before
but using the variation and the
technique of the woman yeah so now you
will start in the front
yeah like this because you will start
with a side step to the right and then
the two steps back yeah so we will do
everything opposite as what we did
before
then you will place your arms like this
woman embrace
yeah right arm up yeah and then you
start with a fitting zero position and
your weight on the
left foot because you start with the
right side step and then you use the
four stages for the step yeah so
projection push and slide transfer of
weight and close for the right side step
i'm doing small because i don't want to
get out of the frame of the camera but
you should do it big yeah big side step
and then you do two back steps starting
with the left leg and you rotate the hip
rotate the hip towards the free leg yeah
so that the toes are pointing a bit
outside and the heel inside then
projection push and slide and when you
transfer the weight you correct the
position of the free foot so that when
you close the free leg
and pass through zero position your feet
are more or less parallel okay and then
another back step rotate the hip
push and slide
change of weight yeah transfer weight
and close then you do a side step to the
left
projection push and slide transfer close
and then you finish with two front steps
in which you keep your hip straight yeah
if you want you can use a bit of
dissociation of the torso you rotate the
torso towards the free leg projection
push and slide
transfer weight close projection push
and slide transfer weight close
and then you are again in the beginning
and you start okay
so we will do
the
combination eight times and we will do
it slowly yeah the metronome is set to
play
only bits yeah
and we will use one beat
for each stage
of the step yeah so it would be
projection push and slide transfer close
okay
so let's do it together
arms in tango embrace for the woman
fit in zero position weight on the left
and we start with a right side step
let's go
one
back
side
front
back
[Applause]
[Music]
three
back
side
front
round
four
from
front
five
back
from
side
front
six
back
side
[Music]
seven
back
side
but
back
side
throw
so
unfinished
okay
great
let's go
to the last extra exercise okay in this
last extra exercise we'll repeat the
rectangle using the combination of the
woman so starting with the side step to
the right and then the two back steps we
will use the technique of the woman so
arms like this yeah
left arm in front of you right arm up
and we will rotate the hip every time we
go back yeah we will rotate the hip
towards the free leg
so that the dogs are looking a bit
outside and here inside yeah
and then after the push and slide when
you transfer the weight you correct the
foot a little bit the back foot a little
bit
so that when you close the free leg and
you pass through zero the two feet are
more or less parallel they do not need
to be exactly parallel but close to
parallel okay
so we will do it fast that means the
metronome now we play
two divisions
yeah
and the stages of the step yeah
projection push and slide transfer and
close will be one two three four one two
three four okay
and we will do it twice eight times okay
remember that my side step is small but
only because i don't have space without
going out of the camera field yeah but
you should do it big okay
okay
so let's get ready
arms in london breaks
feet in zero position straight posture
and your weight is on the
left leg and you start with the right
side step okay
let's go
one
back
side
front
back
side
front
from
three
[Music]
back
side
front
five
back
side
front
six
back
side
front
seven
back
side
front
tape
back
back side
front
one
back
side
front
from
back
side
front
three
back
side
front
from
back
side
front
six
back
side
from
front
seven
back
side
front
eight
back
start back
side
front
okay and that's it
good
so
it
it also helps for the man to try this
yeah
usually the hip and start with the back
steps
so um i hope you like the class practice
this a lot because it will help your
basic working a lot both speeds yeah if
you want to expand this training you can
also combine speeds you can do some
steps
slow and some steps fast in the same
combination it's up to you or change the
side of the steps yeah
front steps do them
short do them long
whatever you want so thank you very much
for watching practice a lot thank you
for the people who are supporting the
channel with your donations that really
helps a lot thanks a lot
and i will see you in the next video bye